do use a fake Starbucks name I do not
actually why what's your name Zack
that's pretty easy oh my god that's my
Pig Starbucks named emer is that really
a fixer no hi my name is Amal and I make
videos at BuzzFeed now I know what
you're thinking that girl has a weird
name she probably uses a fake name when
she goes to Starbucks
I don't but some of you know the drill
you get in line about to order your
favorite drink and you pull out your
trusty fake name you know the classics
Jon Karl or my personal favorite
Gertrude today we'll see what your fear
of bust feeders use as their fake names
when they go to Starbucks all to avoid
social interaction let's go
what's your fake name okay and what's
your real name ku illa Lenny
okay because if I ever tried to say Clos
Lenny they would just look at me with
their mouth a gape like who what where
my fake name is horchata Jose my real
name is Sergio my fake name is David and
what's your real name
Armand my real name is on my credit card
and nobody's been like hey this doesn't
match well you're now exposed so if I
want to have like fun I'll use like Axel
Foley Oh like Theo Huxtable you seem
like a Theo to me my fake name is Kelly
and what's your real name
Kirby like the videogame the pink little
pink ball okay what's your fake name
Lauren and what's your real name
my real name is Salaam my name is
actually supposed to be pronounced Selim
so your real name is your fake name
ken do you have a fake name when you go
to Starbucks my fake name is actually
Ken so I moved to the state's when I was
12 or 13 and I still went by my real
name which is uh kill Hey well thanks
for lying to me for all these years ken
I've only known you for three months but
okay what's your fake name a row name is
one notch good so don't take this the
wrong way but you're not giving me Bob
vibes they know I'm not a bob but it's
like it's a it's an understanding they
appreciate that I'm not wasting their
time they're not wasting my time I will
give any J name I'll say John Jamiroquai
Jacob or Joe Murray Payton as one word
just to see my real name is Jarrett and
they've spelled it so wrong so many
times that I started a hashtag on my
Instagram what's your fake name dilly
dilly I'm your real name Danny Rosenberg
so instead of making it easier for them
you're actually making it harder for
them a little bit I like to spice up
their day you know they have to say a
lot of names so yelling out dilly dilly
is kind of oh well there you have it
folks
the good the bad and the awkward do you
use a fake name of Starbucks let us know
I'm gonna get some coffee
how does it feel like to be a fake
Starbucks name Oh Zach is like a fake
it's a popular name I mean sure you know
I kind of like that actually people are
like trying to be me trying to use my
name
[Music]